so I'm going to say some stuff right now
I'm gonna slice it up but okay hey
welcome to the first ever sticks out
podcast or whatever it's going to be
interview and here I have with me Nick
Weasley introduce yourself
what where are you Nick I'm at Wilde Sun
and jungle resort and Animal Rescue
Center in Costa Rica a lot about place
to be oh what a I gotta ask I feel like
people listening got asked this question
what kind of ant what is the wildest
animal you've seen on location like what
like I'm just turning we've got some
well it's got about four howler monkeys
um and two white face markings around
them dinner that's super cool and you've
got the one I've I've hung out with the
most is they had a baby anteater
the mother was sealed by a falling tree
in the hotel brought it called and they
went and got it so uh one of my duties
for a while was the in here to you know
we want to keep him kind of foraging so
he keeps developing his abilities to
live on his own so every day I take him
and I put him in different places that
have ants but then he tries to climb the
trees and then I you know to let him go
so high and he's amazing the anteater is
just the most amazing little animal so
now we've set him up we built the new
home for him around a tree that we had
lived the bed so that he can be on his
own and that's good for him but I I miss
being able to take him on the ant walks
so perhaps you found your spirit animal
I'm guessing or is this so cool so this
little guy so real quick let's so maybe
some people I'm going to make not make
the assumption that people know who you
are but I'm going to give you a
grandiose introduction and you should
add whatever you'd like but so Nick has
the company playboy which for the past
I'm guessing twelve
- 15 years yeah I guess since 2003 I
mean I started pulling 2001 I think I
got the Playboy URL in 2003 and so
you've traveled the entire world
you've taught on the Internet to become
tough call now I guess with Drex but
probably still the most popular YouTube
boy spinner just sort of in the universe
and so that gives you a place for sure
and namely first in YouTube is one way
to say it in addition but in addition
it's like a consistency and I'm just
like a huge fan I when I first just to
give everybody some knowledge I learned
boy from Matt Terry and your videos
those are my two spots that I learned
all of my point in the beginning and it
was kind of funny because I always just
to be honest like I always like that
like man that guy Nick is just really
nice this guy Matt Terry looks like a
guy I would meet at the spin gym you
know we kind of had more of that
dreadlock image so for some reason I
think I related more to Matt than you
but I also saw more content coming from
you so it was like oh man this is like
all we got and I was really amazed just
how you guys could do stuff like that
when there was really nothing happening
this is kind of an interesting I have a
question for you
so so now that like things are I mean
obviously the way you view this whole
flow arts thing has changed over the
years but um like for where you were
when you started and where you are now
like what are the biggest changes that
you've seen like happen to yourself and
even to the community around you whether
it's flow are to the people you serve as
a huge question but you surround
yourselves around sort of three that's
what kind of three questions I mean I've
had my own my own journey with ploy and
those are howler monkeys in the
background by the way here's something
on closer though I think those are wild
howler monkeys that are probably coming
out to check out the how the markets we
have in rehabilitation I
my my personal practice of play probably
peaked or when I turn 2010 and now is
the year that I started really having
trouble with my shoulder and the
troubles have had with my shoulders that
really affected my my boy thing
and I've gone through phases of
practicing since then but it's never
been the same because a kind of sucks
not knowing what's going to make it
worse what I need to be careful with
there's some things I know are okay
there's some things I know are bad and
then it's a lot of things where I'll
only find out if they're good or bad by
doing them until my shoulders worse and
if I showed where gets worse it might
take months to sort of get it back to
what whatever progress I've made
so have you have you kept motivated
during you know like basically
potentially losing the ability to do poi
like how have you kept stayed motivated
beyond that well I mean I I just I've
just done other things like I've since
2010 I've been through all kinds of ways
of doing aqua yoga or hands down to
blues dancing to power it was in a way
like a motivation just to do other
things so I I come back and do support
and then I go okay maturing care for
this white-faced month so there it's
places around my keys um but up until
2010 like the first you know for the
first ten years of doing for I really
maintain a steady practice like I was I
was doing it a lot and two things I mean
I also what happened was what was
motivating me in all those first years
kind of a vision of how I wanted to be
able to spin when around 2010 I could
spin that way like I could flow with poi
in a way that was yeah that was the
vision and in a way was like what what's
next right and then I I assure see
people doing like tech boy stuff it's
beyond me you know like oh I can try to
get into three point
a four-player I see people do any stuff
that's sort of beyond the level I ever
got today but that wasn't my vision I
kind of achieved my original vision in a
certain way
and then and then once I go oh maybe
I'll take up guitar right and that I
started being interested in other things
so voice continued to be there's a lot
of things about it that's still
interests me like lately it's been the
photography that I'm really interested
in having a lot of fun with but that raw
desire to just pick up the phone and
practice it's been a lot more you
consistent son hmm but then I guess
finding other things whether they're
related to poi or not has sort of given
you new breath to some small extent
within POI hey I'm assuming yeah yeah me
not I think anything inherently things
any creative pursuit informs all the
other ones so for sure like the years I
was in Vancouver they call those dance
classes those are definitely affecting
the way I moved I can see when I see
videos of me I'm dancing one since then
see that that that affected what I do
um as far as what I've seen in to play
world I mean the whole tech polite thing
happens you know that was not happening
and when I was starting there weren't
you know there was like there was I
would travel and there was a grown even
and Matt Perry and Andy honey Cheney and
I really have to track down the spinners
who were really here because I was care
of people or see videos and there was a
number of years when I was I was the
case there was like a small from what I
could see on the internet or in real
person there is a small amount of people
that had already pushing the level and
then it went boom right all of a sudden
there's like hundreds of people that are
spinning on a high level and that's
because of there's a flourishing of
YouTube you know everybody Bing up the
content on the air and there's also a
flourishing of events so you know like
at first
when I in my early days there as fire
drums and people were lying there was a
good boy that Rob for burn was doing and
that was about it and he was burning man
JC and the he JC they hated the place
spinners back then is there like where
are you guys well are you coming TV you
can see but then it started boom boom
and all of a sudden there was wildfire
now it's backfiring like from others
2030 events happen with a year in the
States now Weimer I would guess more
right yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean the
whole art form just kinda went went and
OPEC my thing happen and along with that
also there was also a bit of a change I
don't go to the American events I got
banned from the States but all over the
coach at I also came aware that there
are certain to be a lot more kind of
trolls like a bit of a harsher attitude
that became that I see online that
maturities I don't I don't encounter
that in person because the people who
come to my events the people who like me
and people from you know they see me as
ice on this mild-mannered self-effacing
and kind of fall along and people get
attracted to that are really sweet
people so the people come to my events
are most any kind of shy self-effacing
people so they're great yeah that's a
great I like them but I don't think it's
a good cross-section of who might go to
the festivals right or what's actually
okay where do you think that I'm just
just is a crazy question come what do
you think that comes from that trolling
attitude I'm just curious like is it
Evan is it a or is it I don't know I'm
just curious yeah I wondered um I don't
know I mean I just mostly like seeing
some the forms on a Chuck where I
started being like bones it's like
and it can be great there's also lots of
great people in HR but I've seen
sometimes I've seen conversations all
hear of conversations that get pretty
green cutting some of that's a lot yeah
some of that new foods
I mean if it's the same kind of thing I
just yummy to like the way you know like
you to see a TED talk and you look at
the comments there's always like you
know young guys are you know very nice
they're kind of like Pentagon anything
it was a bit of a shame to see that a
common element of like the boy forums
but I just be inevitable that it's just
at large right there's a certain
percentage of young people who basically
going along kind of or the cut of it
down know why they do it right yeah no
that's I mean it's super interesting I
just thinking as you were mentioning
this as in 2010 this is this kind of a
random note for anybody watching but I
think I had a really long conversation
with you outside of sideshow studios in
Vancouver British Columbia out front
talking to a long time about the Blues
dancing or that for the dancing you were
getting into right around that time just
interesting just like full circle
conversation at the moment I'm like whoa
you've said this to me before but we've
only seen each other maybe a total twice
ever oh so okay cool let me ask you
something else where are you going with
poi what's happening like what's Nick
gonna do like oh well lately I've got a
real um I've been didn't buy the you
know the photography II haven't really
been interesting you you know both
wistfully but also how it started some
of it was a few times I've wanted to
take the other key further but this time
I decided you know before things been
trying to work with photographer and
somehow some months back I started like
he's like no I wouldn't wear any photos
it started learning more and then I
started learning about taking photos of
a milky way how to do it and then I
started planning since she's realizing
it's really fun to get a vision
especially with something like when you
want to like pull out under the Milky
Way and takes a lot of planning it's
like well where's the Milky Way going to
be right where do we want to do it what
apps do I use what will that help what
kind of lens do I need who do I
collaborate with becomes a small project
in the vision that I want a spoon pull
anyway I really like that kind of
artistic project hmm and then I went
through a phase where I was when I was
in Guatemala J months back when I sunny
was just four days I was just having all
these visions of different kind of
follow someone think and they're not led
to go on online just looking at good
photography you know they're looking
through photo Awards and she's getting
inspired the photographer skis I'm going
to getting back even back into the ideas
I was having before you know I had a
listed like fifty sort of visions of
shots I wanted Hey and then what's fun
is every time I go out and try to do
something is that of course know it's
all it's never quite what I it's always
you know it's pitiful so I'm tired and
it's also financing like background
Guatemala I just started looking forward
on the calendar in like the Milky Way
you need a new moon and sort of mapping
out like I think one of the new news for
this year where we're going I just
booked an air B&B means and friends and
agreed to go to one of the Canary
Islands and I riff a I see them on my
globe as one of them way out there
islands that and it's one of the one of
the best places in the world even right
sky because it's a it's out in the
Atlantic it goes up to like I know
fifteen thousand was really high they've
got an observatory on top 300 clear days
a year sunny almost every day and
apparently from what I've seen photos of
is from the top you're just like you're
in space
and the Isles got beautiful the island
itself is eclipsed using federal forest
law for me and so yeah we're going there
kind of on a photo so fun cool
so photos mapping with the hole here
where I'm going to be for the Milky Way
shots into the full moon shots and you
know going up north and some tempura to
do it like the Northern Lights nah
and it all takes like to learn any of it
like the Northern Lights is logging in
to know to get you [\h__\h] because of it
can see each of those projects is that
learning a lot of a photography learning
all about how do you capture phenomena
like that like have you find the
Northern Lights and then going and then
finding your place to shoot it right so
then it's like oh could I do it so
you're gonna add poi is it gonna be are
you gonna like to run out there with
some glow poi and every once in a while
okay and what I want my a lot photos
when doing lately I just need but what I
want is to start doing shots we have a
landscape and we have like I know
several of us so maybe like it doesn't
of us like out across the landscape
rotational formation so all these people
making a play or on you know in sort of
via a map where everybody's gonna be
y'all got a plan and a way to
communicate on megaphone converts didn't
really word sounds awesome and already
got some crazy photo and it's gonna be
like the Northern Lights above us and
voice critters information landscape so
we're so transitioning to so
photos are the new future for Nick seems
like that's awesome it's interesting too
because it seems like a lot of I mean I
guess it's just normal but a lot of
spinners get into photo being
photographers or DJs I can think of
Nikki Evers or willow as easy examples
of top of my head but so I guess as a as
a couple more questions I guess we can
let you go I guess some what what kind
of like what kind of advice would you
offer not just to somebody because I
it's interesting because you are just
too kind of preface it you're sort of
the dream
of the online tutorial spinner basically
right like I want to be reckoned I'm
just being honest or I may not be like a
financial might not feel like that
financially but in terms of like where I
just want to be honest and where people
would like to be somewhere where Nick is
or maybe Drex and clearly there's some
issues with people getting there and
maybe not even a viable lifestyle in a
lot of ways but like what kind of ice
would you give to people who are trying
to make tutorials online and just trying
to get out there like should they yeah
I'm just curious like what would you say
from your years of experience because
that's really what you've been doing
like from a financial standpoint from
like a reward standpoint like what kind
of advice would you give somebody
getting into trying to share their
knowledge with other people yeah I wish
I knew myself and for some things like
2010-2011 I was also when my videos were
getting a lot more hips back then I came
here when I was in Bali 2010 I put the
video and within weeks it had 40,000
hits and now it's been like the last few
years it's a notice of various reasons
for that and maybe it's time to retire
but my videos don't get nearly as many
hits and that makes it it doesn't make
it let's motivate it when like I was
really proud of some of the videos I was
putting up couple months back with the
overlays mm-hmm some of those videos I
was really proud of those I mean I was
there like the background that overlays
explore is like this is like the best
stuff I've ever made and like of those
videos to learn about live three circles
makes for anti-spin which i think it's a
really important subject that confuses a
lot of people two months later it's had
10,000 hits um but the random video I
made of like you know like the iPhone
versus the sony a6000 your camera that's
a twenty thousand that's the only video
I put up in like a couple years I've
been really got a you know a lot of hits
and it's just people are searching if
you do like iPhone versus showing a6000
it's like the number one
but I kind of wish I knew how to do I
would like to I would like to get a
couple more years ago --them Utley I
think I need at some point I'll just
retire from this I would love to know
what my next you know what what I'm
gonna do I I don't I don't know I'm
hoping maybe it'll be something related
no photography and videography but I
would love to get all the hits back up I
was trying to launch this I've been
working on this play map of the world
and that's been a project I've been
trying to ask for eight years now and I
have my Karma hiring programmers is at
least as bad as my karma conveniens bad
but yeah eight years of trying to do the
map and and it's the lesson thinking
well so I'm trying to find people who
might want to collaborate and because my
I mean the internet keeps changing so my
ideal was offer something new that's
really useful you know I get so sick of
all the internet guru stuff the you know
build your list and like offer free
people and all that stuff I think I
think it's all a lot of junk well I
thought you know wonder if I can offer
resources actually really useful there's
something I think you want to community
needs that's a win-win situation
offering something it should be good for
everybody who help people organize
events at their local spin jam go and
find other people to play with it could
really be used for and in doing that I
could help promote my events as well so
as I this is a limb for everybody and
you have to actually take off but for
making
just for making videos I mean it's
really about find your style and and not
be afraid of letting your personality
come through and one of my successes
just don't make it too complicated I do
this often love with with optimism
because I've had sometimes it's just get
stuck out I see a lot of people you know
they think I wanted to get a vision and
then it never gets finished because that
they want all the things all the layers
and all the decimals of that and then
they never finish it well in the last
few years I have increasingly taken
let's just roll the camera maybe I have
to shoot at five times so let's keep it
really simple so I get something out
that's really helped me to keep making
videos in the past years is because if
you set it up are you going to need to
do like days and editing there's a good
chance you'll never do it but if you say
if you say and this is the same advice
you say if you want to start running if
you set the goal I'm going to run for
200 Sevareid a you're almost guaranteed
to be dead in the water
but if you make your goal okay no three
times a week I'm just going to put my
running shoes on and get into front door
and at least get them into the block
that's the goal you use on the ski hit
to the other bar I can come back if I
don't feel like it
the goal is to be using with you when
people do that they have a much much
higher success rate and what happens is
a few months later they're they're
running um but they did it by making the
gold smell so I think the same advice
goes for getting up content is tell
yourself just go out and shoot anything
it's trying to shoot something and then
and then look through it and find
something like it yeah no I heard some
interesting things you said there's two
things that I heard in that little I
heard number one it was this interesting
for you even to say that sometimes and I
think maybe anybody that are
creators online I am I'm one of drex's
patreon people and you just mentioned
video didn't do as well or something
like that that he didn't want and it's
funny to see that all these people that
are like bigger community whatever
visual like that the validation of being
seen is still of like a thing so that
was just interesting to see you say that
because I mean I feel that way all the
time too you know I it's not just for me
it's also but it's not really just that
the reason it hits I've got my whole
career tied up in all of this which by
the way think twice before you do that
that's what is what I like to say but
what do you mean by that thing twice
where you do that a lot of people have a
sense they think you know like wow so
great you're making your career or to
something in love what they forget is
the reason they love it is the cut is
partially because they're only doing it
for fun right the moment you take thing
that was planning to try to make your
job out of it it's not as fun with all
of a sudden like whether or not you get
it brings it all the stress on and free
like a lot of I fall on my face for
every time something's work I've fallen
flat my face and I'm like and I have
[\h__\h] up
I've missed up a lot of things you know
like the map and people get like it's
like the hundreds in a hundreds of hours
like I have tendinitis because of all
the typing and all the computer work and
it's I have still nothing to show
anybody like that that can suck and hey
it's like there's a lot of you know a
lot of people you know you try to turn
what was your hobby something you love
and you make it for work most of us most
of the fire spinners I know who did that
I see them a few years later and they're
just off to another wedding to do
another before and they don't like it
anyway and it can be great I mean some
people
through it a mr. Leggit but a lot of the
time when people turn there they're not
work thing that they'd like you to work
um it all gets you know it all yourself
esteem and your stress and when people
think oh yeah but here's what money
fellas like money stresses you I mean if
you get fired from your job or if your
boss said oh actually we're going to pay
you a third of what we're paying you
that might affect you and it affects me
too like if suddenly crying nice last
year might even comments all down to
like half a third of what it wasn't it
was never much that I now know this last
year I mention less than I live on looks
like what do I do
white rates I'm stressing ya know is
mushroom no that's that I mean shoot you
know man that's the question of all
questions I always tell people I know
it's like usually when you're really
good at a job people want to pay you for
it and you don't want to do it anymore
like that's like the reverse of it you
know like you kind of are losing at
least for me I've like I find myself you
know I do floor it's work too and I ask
you the question thinking the same thing
to me like why do I keep doing this I
think for me I'm really good at a
constant evaluation of why I do this and
I'm like I keep in my mind you know what
I could just walk away any time not to
be mean or anything like that but I mean
like if I needed to step back for
example I can think what a lot of
community members that have had to step
back like zan or I mean everybody I'm
like the oldest guy at all these
American festivals of there's a few
others that have been around as long
like Chris Robo and some other guys in
the scene but not really I mean
literally probably 90% of the people
that I started this whole thing with
like are gone doing owning businesses
some passed away I mean just so many
different things that have happened to
all these people so it's it's
interesting we just kind of brings up a
bigger thing which is like you said the
word career that was the other thing
else can I mention like just a
revaluation of what a career meetings
because I mean in some ways yourself and
me and
other people their career is flow arts
but it's just interesting like when I'm
you know you know something else my body
is gone and whatever like what did that
career mean was it meaningful to me and
I think why I keep doing is I think
about that every day every day I'm like
man like not that I'm denying that I
like spinning and stuff that really
still do and everything's awesome but I
always like to just because I've had
this caucus why I had this conversation
recently with the guy who messaged me
and he had problems with somebody that
were taking his tricks and showing him
online or getting all this credit was
feeling a little frustrated about it and
you know I feel that way too sometimes
right like you know I've felt that way
about tricks I felt that way about
business models I felt that way about a
lot of things and sometimes when you
make it your business you have to change
the way you think about it right like
everything becomes more personal or
something maybe that's something is like
you know if you were not to get as many
views maybe that means not as much
money's coming in for you you know it's
kind of perfect that's exactly priest
fact boy look my frustration with the
videos not getting as many hits he said
it's because my career's all tied up in
that because I I want same thing like
last year's my events
they get pull enough that people have a
great time but not pulling up or I'm
making money and I'm free I'm 43 now and
it's like I'm making most years and
money that would be great if I was in my
twenties but I'm beginning to have like
a lot of dental work I might need and
some more concerns about what I'm what I
going to do
and I get concerned about that so I kind
of wish I had another job I could do I'm
hoping I think of something is it would
be nice if I had a bit more of a secure
way to to know I'm paying my rent and
then and then I wouldn't terror whether
the videos revolving buyer or not
because it wasn't like whether it is
right now so I'm except in my mind all
whether or not I ever have a garden
whether or not ever have a home whether
or not I have a I start earning money
way later you know sort of it's too much
involved with whether these videos are
going to get hits and whether or not
things go up or down hmm
no that's yeah that's interesting
because such a side of this I mean this
is what I like this little pocket I'm
gonna be honest is that a you know
there's such a side of what we do that
is kind of hidden you know like when you
mentioned people are trolls online
probably a lot of those people are
pretty good people I can be completely
honest they are good people and I think
a lot of people that are seen as really
like famous or like yourself or Drax or
other people I mean they're working
their butts off and it's no joke to try
to make this thing work or other hustles
that make this thing work or whatever it
is you know like I teach little kids
science right that's my side hustle that
keeps me in this game you know but it's
like I I think there's a side of this
that a it might be good when people
start to get started that I mean what I
hear from you is it's okay also to be a
hobbyist I feel like that's like such a
forgotten thing in this this flow world
like it's okay to be not technically
skilled to dress up with your fancy
clothes and to go out there and rock
fire like that's awesome
you know you could practice once a year
for all I care you know like I mean you
know I mean safely I'm supposed to but
like you know like I think that there's
such a distorted opinion on what a
career means and what your future could
look like and how much work that
actually takes and how difficult that
actually is to do so yeah I really
appreciate you sharing that because I
vibrate a lot on that okay just to wrap
this up because I shoot Nick that was an
amazing conversation I feel even though
it seemed really sad and there were
moments that I person it's only sad
because I'm seeing us it's like mirror
vibe you know I'm seeing like oh man
like you know I'm seeing that and I
think that's a new part of your story
that is trying to come out is that you
know you are such an amazing mirror of
what it means to have something that's
had a career in the floors it's
interesting because I've known a couple
of those people you know we can use Dan
or Linda as interesting example the
people that passed away that basically
to some extent they're cool
I mean their career wasn't their future
and career was engaged in flow arts and
they met an end in one
way and then you have the people that
maintain flow arts that are still around
right that that haven't decided and it's
just such an interesting man just kind
of amazing to me just thinking about all
of that and you know even thinking of
people like just yeah just right now
someone could listen to this and
reevaluate the career choices which in
my mind it's a good thing it just like
I'm just going to just be like I'm gonna
be the best contact a sprinter ever and
I'm gonna be a computer programmer -
that sounds like right call right you
know so yeah that's often when I
actually recommend although I you know
also a lot of people like there's a lot
of people who could be better at what I
do than I am like I'm going to making
the videos but I don't think I've been
very good I think I bungle all the
career parties hmm I mean it's a path
right you know like it's a path and
we're all any different ones so Nick so
right now do you have any retreats
coming up before we leave you want to
let anybody know about or anything
exciting here we go first one is - West
Coast beating your Vancouver Isaac that
spins that space yeah and people people
spend like at Leviathan if I add up how
many hours I see people just actually
playing with toys Leviathan blows
everything out of the water it's just
people just keep getting pulled back
onto the floor and they just play like a
wind-up dolls or like everything adult
I'm incredible I'll be back here a wild
son next year I really like what Jeremy
is doing with the space like it's just
such a special place we're talking about
Jeremy on the being is that yeah I mean
a pool I know just wild songs I got the
whole animal rescue [\h__\h] chamber
they're doing it's uh if people come
here there's really this is the vibe
here people early touched with them I'll
be back here a bunch and if I find the
right people to maybe collaborate with
these low Maps the world and
yeah I've uh I've heard a little musings
that's you say the word programmer just
get developer I'm just go the tag out of
that pass set and okay cool well thank
you Nick
I really appreciate you taking a second
it looks like you know life is amazing
regardless of wherever your careers that
life looks amazing over there I mean
holy moly kind of feel like visiting now
and girlfriend is really going out of
town so maybe so thank you for your time
and reach out anytime and you guys
anyone at home can check out Nick at
playboy.com and support him because he's
doing amazing things and he's I hope to
see you in the future
bye Wow